barcelone a confiné suite à une hausse
des cas de covile 19 près de 4 millions
d'habitants sont appelés à rester chez
eux ces deux prochaines semaines
le gouvernement régional a interdit les
réunions de plus de 10 personnes dans
toute l'agglomération
tout comme les visites dans les maisons
de retraite il a aussi limité la
capacité d'accueil des bars et
restaurants à 50%
en effet ces dernières 24 heures ce sont
1300 nouveaux cas qui ont été détectés
en catalogne
les citoyens de toutes ses municipalités
doivent rester chez eux dès qu'ils ne
leur est pas indispensable de sortir
c'est la consigne que nous donnons il
dépend de vous tous que la contagion ne
se propage pas et nous vous recommandons
dans cette mesure également de ne pas
vous déplacer dans des résidences
secondaires pendant ce week-end en
israël également retour des restrictions
pour le week end jusqu'à dimanche matin
restaurants salles de sport coiffeur
grandes surfaces bibliothèque ou encore
muse et resteront fermés les plages
elles aussi seront fermés tous les
week-ends à compter du 24 juillet des
mesures que le gouvernement de benyamin
nétanyahou qualifie d'intermédiaire afin
d'éviter un confinement générale les
mesures que nous présentons les
recommandations portent principalement
sur la façon d'arrêter les
rassemblements d'empêcher les
rassemblements dans les espaces fermés
de plus de 10 personnes et de plus de 20
dans les espaces ouverts
ce n'est pas scientifique
il y a toujours des exceptions cependant
c'est notre décision afin d'empêcher ces
rassemblements
l'alternative aux mesures que nous
prenons aujourd'hui seraient des mesures
beaucoup plus dures à prendre demain
ce que nous essayons d'éviter
il se pourrait que nous n'ayons pas le
choix et que nous devions les prendre
mais pour le moment nous tentons de
prendre des décisions rapides et
conjoints en inde
un million de personnes sont désormais
infecté malgré la multiplication des
restrictions sanitaires le pays déplore
plus de 25 mille morts depuis le début
de la pandémie
quant au bilan des décès quotidiens ils
continuent de grimper et s'établit à
plusieurs centaines 700 morts ont été
enregistrés pour la seule journée de
jeudi
le nombre de cas en inde augmentent très
rapidement
ce vendredi nous avons 35 mille nouveaux
cas en une seule journée c'est bien sûr
tout le monde a très peur
s'amuse un puissant parce que tout ce
qui doit être fait ne peut l'être que
par des gouvernements ou par des
médecins
un million de cas en inde c'est vraiment
effrayant et inquiétant j'espère que les
choses vont être contrôlés qu'ils vont
trouver des médicaments rapidement et
qu'ils seront disponibles pour tout le
monde
en chine un nouveau foyer a été repéré
dans la région du xinjiang au nord-ouest
du pays où réside la minorité musulmane
ouïghoure la capitale régionale urumqi
qui compte trois millions et demi
d'habitants a fermé son métro tandis que
le nombre de liaisons aériennes avec la
métropole a été fortement réduit à
melbourne en australie le nombre de cas
s'envole la deuxième ville du pays a
enregistré plus de 400 nouveaux cas en
24 heures jeudi un chiffre inédit depuis
fin mars en dépit du rpt confinement
décidé il ya plus d'une semaine
à ce jour la pandémie a fait plus de 590
milles morts dans le monde quant au
nombre de cas officiellement
diagnostiqué
il est de plus de 13 8 millions dans 196
pays et territoires